I think a burger might be the perfect
food you've got this juicing meat top
with some melted cheese different
textures different tastes it covers
every base it's everything you could
want and you pick that burger up if it's
not juicing all over the damn place it
ain't a real burger but I got to say the
tastiest burger in all of LA is the
father's office burger definitely at
Cassell's has to be planned checked the
tastiest burger I've ever had is at
Cassell's in Koreatown the burgers come
on a bun and have all the toppings on
the side so you can create your perfect
burger which i think is part of the fun
and what makes it so special you know
when you take that first bite
it's exactly how you were picture the
best burger ever to be they're not
trying to put fancy ingredients on it
they're not trying to change what a
burger is it's just really simple
quality ingredients that are just
assembled in the perfect way my name is
Christian Paige and I'm the chef and
owner of Cassell's hamburgers in Los
Angeles and I'm gonna show you how to
make our burger guess I was opened in
1948 and what made it such a popular and
you know famous place is that every day
alka cell is getting up in the morning
and he's in the window and he's grinding
meat we still do the same thing which is
take really well marbled Chuck's then we
grind it into a really coarse grind like
this so you end up with a much stickier
bite and all we do with the patty is
just simply season it with a little
pepper and a good amount of salt and
then it goes onto this grill and what we
do is we keep it at 500 degrees so
that's how you get that nice crust which
is like what separates a well-cooked
burger my yard reaction that my yard
reaction that's what she's like yeah
do it you like cheddar cheddar I like to
go to pieces of cheddar like so though
for the bun it's not a brioche bun what
you would call like I guess like a
Portuguese bun so the beef fat shines
through instead of the butter fat and
that's a burger right there it's simple
it's delicious it's juicy it's
everything you wanted a burger you can
make it your own you're gonna try to
convince me that it's the best one it oh
it is the burger will do all the
convincing okay for us it's all about
doing the simple things well you know
that's why we put everything on the side
and the burger is just the bun the meat
and the cheese and it's all about the
meat all right here goes I'm speechless
how are you doing I'm concerned this is
incredible I still think that my burger
is a very good burger this is also a
very good classic when you want a burger
this is what you want you were talking
about how the focus is on the meat and
the bun and it's like yep even when I
put all the toppings on like when I take
that big bite the person that hits me is
just the mean and like the salt and yes
like if really he's in blunt and center
yes
[Music]
hello there I'm going to the gym tonight
all right sounds great but the tastiest
burger to me is still plan Shack
so once the burger arrives you pick it
up the first thing you taste is that
juicy meat coming back to me now and I'm
just like having a foodgasm thinking
about it okay back to you right and then
you taste the ketchup leather oh my word
this ketchup leather takes it to a new
level what it does is it kind of blocks
the juices that are coming from the
burger and makes it so that your bun
doesn't get soggy which can be a common
problem with a juicy burger hi my name
is Shawn yawns I'm the corporate chef
for a plan check kitchen and bar I'm
gonna show you how to make the plan
check burger the PCB we're gonna start
with the most important part this 50/50
short rib Chuck we're gonna salt it very
good now we're gonna flip boom and
you're gonna see how all that fat has
come up and seared on top of that meat
that's where you're gonna get a lot of
that flavor
this is the Melrose bakery Portuguese
style bun
we put a little truffle butter on their
toast those off a little bit we're going
to top it with our small son yinz these
are cooked down with chicken fat and
chicken skin this is the Americanized
dashi cheese all right we're gonna melt
this so we're going to take our World
Bank world-famous ketchup leather we
take Tomatoes vinegar soy sauce some
spices sugar and then we're gonna puree
this and spread it onto a sheet pan and
dehydrate the ketchup for ketchup
leather square alright and these are our
spicy sriracha pickles you've got the
perfect burger
Alexis literally couldn't so interesting
there's the sweetness of the temple and
that cheese it's like I don't think I've
ever really tasted anything quite like
it
the cheese is a dashi cheese that we
flavor here in-house you guys make your
own G yes
and this is just that hard to pick out
one one star like I said but I mean it's
like everything is perfect now give
you're having a bad day and you're just
like I just want burger you take your
the plain checking you go get Disney I'm
burger I mean what do you think it could
be the best burger no I mean it could be
that was a really really good burger I
will admit that however I still feel
confident saying that father's office is
the tastiest burger in LA chef sang
talks about how he took his inspiration
from French onion soup and the second
you take a bite you get that it's beefy
you get that caramelized onion you get
the cheese crunchy bread it's unlike any
other burger you're gonna get anywhere
else and it's just it's magic the idea
of the gastropub the chef burger a nice
craft beer pretty much you owe that to
chef Tsai if you don't know there's kind
of a no ketchup thing at the father's
some people are bothered by the no
ketchup thing I respect the chef's
opinion the burger is perfect the way it
is it doesn't need
hey everybody I'm chef saying you to
father's office and I'm gonna show you
how to make the office burger dry-aged
patty half a pound what goes into your
grind just chuck coarse salt black
pepper since it is very high-quality dry
aged beef I like to cook it and treat it
as if there was a steak garlic butter we
make a very simple but delicious uni bag
yet almost we all know what a hamburger
bun is like is essentially a piece of
bread you wouldn't want to eat by itself
so why don't we use bread that you would
enjoy as bread and toast brings out the
caramelized flavor right the onion
compote
so when we do is we cook the bacon down
all that it gives us that delicious
bacon fat and let all the onions cook
differently in the bacon fat the bacon
fat that oh it just smells like the best
garlic bread right the best part of
French onion soup in my opinion is
degree our cheese great blanket on yeah
exactly the blue we use a little bit
less so we use this sort of as I call
this the punctuation mark exclamation
point gives that nice salty funky punch
we've got of course melt over boy oh
yeah what is this like three onions
worth it's like an entire onion 1 large
onion yeah that's right not a slight
easy right so arugula yes right that's
all there is to it good what do you
think Nick what's what's what's in here
right now the things that are sticking
out to me the bread is incredible the
Badgers will unreal it's not about the
bread dough that Jam or whatever that
situation it's like the sweet love the
onions with the cheese and the juiciness
of the burger comes together in this
really really beautiful way so what's
the deal with the no condiments this is
the truth is that I actually forgot I
forgot
we forgot to order to catch the first
person to ask me for ketchup the patient
zero he was really angry at me and it
really it was very off-putting I was
like well screw it then I'm not gonna
Wow you don't feel like if you need
ketchup because a chef I didn't do my
job
the beauty of is there's a harmony in
this collection of ingredients
if you remove or add anything it
completely changes the composition yeah
it changes the whole thing so guys what
do you think this possibly the tastiest
burger in LA so all three are obviously
great but my favorite is still
planchette Casals is still my number one
it's the best burger in LA hands down
his neck still at his desk yes okay
plan check was my favorite burger I love
the father's office burger it's so good
but that plan Czech burger today was
just well it was perfect chef sang is
gonna kill me oh yes I don't ever want
to eat a burger ever again
[Music]
you
[Music]